joining us from Russia is Roger Bennett
how are you Roger oh I'm live from the
bird hotel in Moscow how bad can life be
I could just say just so you can
mentally picture it decision federal
aftershave is faintly smellable all over
this fine city it's amazing to be here
for Vladimir Putin soccer team bomb it's
for rich who's lighting the candles at
that Bar Mitzvah Roger what do you think
is a request you cannot turn down it's
been thus far
England footballers they are the ones
who have shocked the world and probably
even more shocked themselves by being
the the kind of Dark Horse young wonders
of this World Cup but that moment you
just played on your show of Ronaldo that
pert show pony stepping up to take a
penalty kick and the ball had the
temerity of allowing itself to be fazed
by the Iranian goalkeeper that was
Leonor Messi's finest finest and
probably happiest moment of this where
ever Messi is I mean and Argentina's
gonna take the pitch shortly I mean we
saw prior to Argentina taking the pitch
the last time he just looked like he was
swallowing his own vomit Roger I don't
know how to read his body language
because I don't I don't normally see him
play too many matches ordinarily is is
Messi spooked do you think going into
this final match Roger I have compared
him to the the process of what's
happening little messy for your
listeners is the single greatest
footballer I have ever seen in my
lifetime and that that does not change
but what happened in this world of weird
this will curve is that he's somehow
morphed into Ralph Wiggum from The
Simpsons so there's been some kind of
unbelievably weird kind of body swap and
I can't quite understand it he is a
gentleman that can lacerate teams
single-handedly when he wants to but
it's watching him in his first two games
has been to see him absolutely drown and
I say coming to Moscow I arrived here
yesterday
it has changed my perspective on the
whole thing you know that sports teams
are fragile cultures and this
Argentinian side have mutiny against
their own coach a little bit I mean I
made the share about the 1998 US team
the World Cup American Fiasco where they
muta need well they all mutiny changed
each other and the mutiny against their
coach it was a disaster this is very
much Argentinean Fiasco but when you
walk around the streets of Moscow rich
Messi's face is on pretty well anything
that moves hears on the side of buses
he's in every shop window he's painted
on the side of houses in advertising
commercials almost every three out of
five television commercials have his
little chirpy little Ewok face popping
out and grinning at you and you watch it
and you realize just that never mind the
sporting pressure of a the whole of
Argentina or watching this little man
saying you need to lead us to victory
the commercial pressure nevermind the
pressure it must be exhausted from
shooting all these commercials but the
weight of the jersey they say in in in
Argentina the weight of the jersey is
literally dragging him down Roger
Bennett men in Blazers and you mentioned
the American fiasco podcast about the
1998 World Cup meltdown by the US Men's
National Team you can download it from
WNYC studios on podcast wherever
podcasts are available
Roger it's interesting you know as you
know now that you're an American citizen
and you're attune to the American sports
fan is even better now Philadelphia
Eagles fans celebrating in a manner that
they're not accustomed to Washington
Capitals fans feeling the same way is it
possible that fans of of England are
feeling the same way right now not not
being able to compute what is actually
happening on the pitch there in Russia
it took it's exactly right I mean I I
wouldn't quite go Philadelphia Eagles
fan levels yet we don't have to greet up
the telephone poles across England right
yet but a winning England an optimistic
England a joyous England I have never
seen that before with my I've watched
England a lot in my lifetime and I have
never seen an England play with smiles
on their face true there means English
pleasure meant to feel do
and they meant to self-sabotage I meant
to reinforce our sense of self-loathing
that a national realization of while we
once had an empire and were truly kings
of the world were now just an
insignificant kind of tiny little scarf
out there in the Atlantic that's what we
expect from our footballers so to see
this young team and it is young
they've shattered the culture of these
legends whose names you some of them you
may know Wayne Rooney Steven Gerrard who
kind of it their whole goal on a
football field was to not get beat too
bad and please don't be the scapegoat
target for the tabloid newspapers this
young team they played joyously they
play with real focus on entertaining
attacking buccaneering football and to
see this young man who's named some of
your listeners may recognize Harry Cade
a young striker who has been made
captain and he's thrived under the
burden of captaincy which is meant to be
like a pair of concrete shoes those
doomed to wear the captain's armband
Thomas Ian I would say Duke of
Wellington I would say Winston Churchill
and I would say Harry Kay he's in that
ether and I'm not being hyperbolic I'm
not exaggerating he said he's the Harry
the what's-her-name probably meant to
marry Roger Bennett here on the Rich
Eisen show which is the best side that
you've seen so far it seems like Oh
again a wide wide open parody filled top
so far so it's and it's also a world cup
of Julius attacking football normally
the smaller teams Iran Morocco Peru
would just try and batten down the
hatches and play you know focus on buddy
Ryan style defensive football but they
haven't that maybe because America Iran
in it the world's one true superpower on
the football field they're like you know
what America Iran in it we've got no one
to fear so last night you saw it Iran
truly try and take down Portugal well at
the same time Morocco showed no fear
against Spain so is a very open it's a
World Cup there's been a Marvel the
greatest World Cup of my lifetime rich
and I say the team that have truly
caught the eye as Argentina falter as
Germany truly falter
has been met
I mean a a remarkable team to watch this
is a team you you love curses in
American sports you know that the curse
of the Bambino the Madden curse this is
a team that in their last six World Cups
our last six has gone out at the very
same round in ever more tragic ways at
the round of 16 they're led by a
Colombian manager Juan Carlos Osorio who
has been despised by the Mexican fans
they've chanted for him to be fired he
shows no respect for the true legends of
the team he b canna benches them he
keeps tinkering with tactics he bit the
relationship between the fans and him
has really burnt out he's come on our
show a number of times and he said you
know what I'm only focused on my team I
don't care what the fans say at this
woke up the fans have chanted his name
with glory if his team shocked Germany
and then stopped South Korea with two
very different performances one counter
attacking the other deeply aggressive
and controlling of the ball they love
his tinkering now they love his his
creativity and to watch a man vindicated
before the eyes of his own fans has been
very moving humanly and he's talked a
lot about the job he wants in soccer
when Carlos Osorio which is ultimately
to be the u.s. manager and to think
about what he could do with our nation
with our team with our players it's hard
not to watch Mexico thrive under his
watch and think what could be in the
United States and yet with Germany
scoring one of the five stoppage time
game-winning goals this World Cup which
is the most since 1966 Mexico's could
still be out if it wasn't for that last
goal by Germany Mexico would be through
right now so there is a possibility
somehow someway of night of a nightmare
scenario coming up when when that group
gets on the pitch Wednesday Roger
yeah the Germany Sweden game for those
who didn't say unbelieving Sweden were
beating Germany Germany are Germany are
Darth Vader you do a you do not beat
Darth Vader very very often and Sweden
had every chance of doing that and just
wilted the German German never more
deadly than when they are their own
mortality is exposed and in the 95th
minute
a piece of alchemy from their midfielder
Toni Kroos where he just lacerated the
ball it was almost like a drone strike
into the corner it was a closest I've
ever seen to witnessing with my own own
eyes that Game of Thrones battle to the
death between the Viper and the mountain
Sweden's the Viper Germany's a mountain
played out in real time it was crisis
averted for the Germans but their
problems and their really are problems
you see them in American sports the
locker rooms that are divided between
the old guard and then you guard between
the kind of flash new newcomers and
that's most stoical veterans they are a
team that is utterly divided there's a
little bit of geopolitical flavor where
they're that they're star midfielder a
gentleman called Mesut özil who's a
German of Turkish origin posed with the
the president of Turkey owed the one
right before the World Cup a move that
did not go down at all well within
Germany and has really created an
incredible geopolitical locker-room
Fischer so the problems with Germany
will not go away in it this is going to
be a World Cup we're a team that has not
won before very much good there's a lot
of lot of eyes on Belgium who are
playing some of the most riffled joyous
true collective football and so as I
said earlier rich this is a single
greatest World Cup of my lifetime and I
just want it to be hooked right up to my
veins I love it me to I've really been
enjoying it last one for you Roger
Bennett been in Blazers last one for you
you can't see unless the Rich Eisen show
is on in Russia but notes to me but I am
in fact asking this question clutching
my bilf
life mug that you were kind enough to
send me you and michael davies sent me
with the men in Blazers logo the crest
on the other side bill flyff which the B
stands for bald everybody else I think
and understand what the rest of it is so
I ask you this Roger Bennett how in the
world do these players and refs and
officials run around as they do for as
long as they do breaking as much of a
sweat as they do and their hair is
perfect what is in the pomade what are
they
using in their hair to keep the parts so
chiseled throughout an entire World Cup
match Roger I'm not sure I'm allowed to
say it on the Rich Eisen show
televisions but I believe it's horse
semen this verify is this a verifiable
fact Roger it's they tell their hair and
brain mascara in many stores it's there
in the FIFA shop is remarkable and
talking about FIFA do you think the Rich
Eisen show is on Russia it's on public
KGB headquarters and monitoring all of
your words they wanted to all of your
words very very carefully rich well now
I mean in I'm just trying to I'm just
trying to figure it out Roger I can't I
mean I'm I'm admittedly very jealous
there is the soccer hair is perfect
baldness is true for it choice and full
missus truth and you're a very very very
handsome bald man but sometimes I do
look at the these footballers and yeah
the Iranian team absolutely glistening
in gorgeous last nigh against the
Spanish team and ultimately I do you
think that football I've always thought
the World Cup is just as become an
incredible fusion of global sports
global television the reach of
television and and commercial
sponsorship it's become an enormous
billboard but this will come looking at
the head looking at Olivier Giroux a
Frenchman run around the field rippling
gorgeous the perfect man watching the
Moroccan case you have a Renard who
looks like it's been ripped with his
shirt open from the front cover of an
arlequin romance novels ultimately
football could just be a platform just
for hair product at the end of the day
they I may have been watching the wrong
thing all at this time was abroad man
it's great to be with you I love your I
love your passion for the game rich nice
Roger really genuinely it's a remarkable
when we've got Rich Eisen loving
football there's not too much else that
we need to win over my mother through
football in Asian and I told you then
I'll tell you I told Michael this I'll
tell you I just love your guys take on
it it's just so much fun and your
passion comes through too and certainly
in the encyclopedia blazer Tanika that
you brought and
you know let's let's chat again next
week Roger I want to tell a man that's
living with it we're the only two men
holding foot holding soccer back from
truly taking off in this country rich
that's what we say about us no well to
be with it now Roger you got horse
racing fans interested so thank you for
that appreciate that
Cheers okay courage there's Roger
Bennett everybody the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience